this penthouse you had was
there was a very
bad situation that happened for people
who don't know well it wasn't at this
point i moved out of that penthouse and
moved to another penthouse so where you
moved for people who don't know there
was a
in la there was a hostage situation yeah
that everyone across the world saw on
online
was it your lady that was being held
hostage she was my friend your friend
was being held hostage at your place
by a guy a gunman correct and the police
the swat team whatever it is blew blew
the wall up or and then
rescued her
yeah killed the dude killed the guy in
my life in your living room yeah you're
not home at the time no you want to know
something that's crazy is um
that was [ __ ] crazy it was very cuz i
was watching and then i saw you post
like that's my home and i was like oh
[ __ ]
the thing that's crazy is is i threw a
little party the night before
and um a couple people stayed over and
whatever and and my friend her name's
haley the one who got um held it
gunpoint
before i left to go to a meeting right i
said don't let no weird don't don't let
no weird crazy [ __ ] in my house i
don't know why i said it i just looked
back i was like don't let no weird crazy
[ __ ] in my house and she laughed she's
like i'm not and i'm like okay cool
and then i leave and i go to this
meeting
and then i'm like calling her trying to
reach out to her and she's not picking
up and i and i'm like that's strange
like why she's not picking up maybe
she's asleep right right and then we get
back to my house and um
the entire street is [ __ ] blocked off
everything is blocked off from here to
[ __ ] 7th street or whatever and i'm
like what's going on and people like yo
it was the shooting it was the shooting
she was shooting i'm like oh [ __ ] you
know it's crazy it's like the gunman ran
into your building now i'm like oh [ __ ]
he's in my building now it's like crazy
calling her she's still not picking up
and something in my gut was like oh [ __ ]
i bet this nigga's in my house only
because crazy [ __ ] happens to me like
this crazy movie weird [ __ ] just happens
and i'm like there's no reason why she
wouldn't be picking up with this this
and i put two and two together and then
um
someone who i was with uh
um well just someone i was with uh was
just like i think someone's in your
house and i'm like uh
oh [ __ ] someone is in my house
so the guy had a bad day he went on a
[ __ ] shooting rampage tried to steal
a car shot someone pulled the trigger at
another dude's head the gun one click
end up running into my building and uh
running into my house and your friend's
okay she's okay i mean outside of the
outside of the drama that's trump this
situation but she's alive you know which
is amazing but you know anything could
have happened and then when they broke
in you know he grabbed her to shield
himself and
he could have went really bad i could
have went really really bad so um so
when they
because there was like an explosion
right
yeah they put c4 on all my doors they
blew they blew up my crib they like blew
up my crib my closet that [ __ ] is like
horrible
so all the [ __ ] that i manifested ended
up getting blown up
which is funny as [ __ ] which is crazy
personal belongings [ __ ] yeah a lot of
them but none of it means anything right
it really doesn't and i can honestly say
that to anybody probably watching this
like you know you you work your whole
life to get new cars and watches and
clothes and clothes and [ __ ]
but they really don't mean anything i
agree man i tell people all the time are
you do you still live there hell no i
don't know they owe me money too santa
fe also owes money if you're a lawyer
watching this i have a million dollar
civil case ready to go get at me because
seriously they update who owes you money
the apartment building or the cops
all of them okay everybody
yeah they kind of blew up your
i mean insurance
the building because the dude shouldn't
have been able to get into the building
there was a security guard that wasn't
on he was working that day but he was
always hollering at women like every
time on netflix or something yeah he was
like every time i see a guy working
security at a building he's got his
phone like underneath the desk he's got
his little earplug yeah yeah he ain't
[ __ ] tripping so he should never been
able to get in that building you know
let alone up to the fourth floor oh the
fourth floor yeah yeah that's a that's
not like a yeah yeah
yeah like
so well at least that your friend's fine
yeah you know physically she's still
here yeah
when you saw that like
what are you what are your thoughts
what's your reaction
i went into imagination time i swear to
god when when
bombs were going off guns was going off
my friends were crying i literally
closed my eyes and i envisioned her
being dragged out of the building alive
i used all of my energy and i didn't
worry everybody else was scared as [ __ ]
i wasn't scared i said she's coming and
that's how you utilize your imagination
you can heal yourself you can heal
someone else you can manipulate a
situation simply by seeing the outcome
and then believing it i guess that's
what people would call faith um